The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, starting again.
I want to begin
with a quick review
of what we said last time.
This time will be
quicker than usual
because we're not really
continuing from there,
we'll be starting a
completely new topic today.
But I thought I'd
remind you, nonetheless,
that we had a last lecture--
the universe was not
created between then and now.
And what we talked
about last time
was the spacetime
geodesic equation,
which is written this way.
It's a completely
identical to the equation
we derived for geodesics
in pure spatial situations.
The only difference really,
is a difference in notation.
Instead of using i
and j the tradition
is to use mu, nu, et cetera
for the spacetime indices which
are sum from 0 to 3, where
x super 0 is identical to t.
And in addition, the parameter
which is sometimes called s
when we're talking about
space, is called tau
when we're talking
about time because what
the parameter refers
to is the proper time
along the trajectory of the
object whose geodesic we're
calculating.
We then introduced the
Schwarzschild metric,
which we did not
derive, but we claimed
it describes the metric for
any spherically symmetric mass
distribution as long
as you're talking
about the region outside
where the masses are located.
And here M is the total
mass of the object, which
is the only thing the
metric really depends on,
G is Newton's constant, and C
is of course the speed of light.
The metric has an
interesting feature
that the coefficients
of both the dt
squared term and to dr squared
term becomes singular either 0
or infinity, depending on
which one you're looking at,
a particular value of the
radius called the Schwarzschild
radius, given by this formula
2 GM divided by c squared.
The bigger the mass the bigger
the Schwarzschild radius,
they're proportional
to each other.
The metric is singular
at those points,
but I mentioned
but did not prove,
that that particular
singularity is
in fact what is referred to
as a coordinate singularity.
It's a singularity that's
there only because of the way
the coordinates were chosen.
So there are other ways of
choosing the coordinates where
that singularity disappears.
There's also singularity
at r equals zero,
and that singularity
is real, there's
no way to remove
that singularity
by a change of coordinates.
However, although r sub s
is not a true singularity,
it is a horizon.
And by that we mean that if any
particle or even a light beam
gets inside the Schwarzschild
radius, it can never get out.
There's no geodesic which will
take it out of the horizon.
And it's not even a
matter of geodesics,
there are no
time-like paths even
if you have a rocket which
would then not follow geodesic.
There's no way to get out
from inside a black hole.
We didn't show that, but
that fact is claimed.
Then we calculated the geodesic
for our radially falling
object.
We solve the problem
of an object that
is released from rest at
some initial value r sub 0,
and just let fall straight
down towards the center
of the sphere.
And the the equation
describing the geodesic
is just a special case
of the general equation
that we had a few slides ago.
And we need only look
at the radial component
if we want to track how the
radius changes with time.
So there was a free index
mu in the generic form
of the equation, we're setting
mu equal to the r variable.
And then the equation
reduces to this form
and we know what these G sub
t t's and G sub r r's are,
they come from the equation
for the Schwarzschild metric
on the previous slide.
And that equation
can be manipulated
and eventually it simplifies
to something extraordinarily
simple.
It's just the statement that
d squared r d tau squared is
equal to minus GM over r
squared, which looks exactly
like the Newtonian equation
for something falling
in a spherically symmetric
gravitational field.
But it's not really
the same equation,
it just looks like it's the same
equation, because the variables
both a different
meanings. r and tau
both have different meanings
from the r and t that
would have appeared in
the Newtonian calculation.
The r variable that
appears here is not really
the distance from the origin.
If you wanted to know the
distance from the origin
you'd have to integrate
the metric singular even--
if not even a well defined
distance to the origin
because the origin singular.
And the tau that appears
here is a time variable,
but it's not the time that would
be read on any fixed clock,
rather it's the
time that would be
read on the wristwatch
of the person falling
into the spherically symmetric
object, which we might consider
to be a black hole.
And we were able to
solve this equation
by using essentially
conservation of energy
techniques, or at least what
would be called conservation
of energy if we were doing
the Newtonian version
of the problem, which is
the same equation even
though the variables have
a different interpretation.
So we were able to calculate
not r as a function of tau,
but at least tau
a function of r.
And we got that equation,
which is a little complicated,
but the interesting
thing about it
is that it gives finite answers
for every value of r going
all the way down
to r equals zero.
So it means that in a
finite amount of time,
as seen by the person
falling into the black hole,
the person would reach r
equals zero, at which point
he would disappear
into the singularity.
He'd actually be ripped
apart as he approached
the singularity
because of tidal forces
which pull more strongly
on the front part of him
than on the back part of him,
stretching the object out
in the radial direction.
However, curiously,
if one calculates
what this trajectory
looks like as a function
of the coordinate time,
t, we did actually
do that calculation
but we looked
at how it would
behave in the limit
as you approached-- as
the particle approached
the Schwarzschild horizon.
And we discovered it would take
an infinite amount of time,
as seen from the outside,
for the in falling object
to reach the horizon, let
go through the horizon
and get to r equals zero.
So from the outside, it
looks like the object never
actually falls into
the black hole,
but just gets closer and closer
and closer as t approaches
infinity.
So it's an example of a very
highly distorted spacetime,
where you can see very
different pictures depending
on which observer you're
trying to describe
the observations of.
And I think that's it.
Any questions about any of that?
I guess I'll put that back up.
OK.
On your homework you'll be
applying this geodesic equation
to a model universe, to
Robertson-Walker universe,
and this will serve only as an
example for those calculations.
I guess there's also a homework
problem about the Schwarzschild
metric, that orbits in
the Schwarzschild metric
that you'll be working at.
It's all in principal
straightforward
if you just look at
equations and follow
what the equations tell
you, thinking carefully
about what the variables mean.
OK.
In that case, let's get
started on today's work,
which is a change of gear.
We're now going to be
talking about black body
radiation and its
effect on the universe.
I should say that
my original plan was
to get into this set
of lectures notes--
lecture notes six, which have
not been handed out yet--
to get into those last time
and to finish them today.
I don't think that's
going to be possible
because I didn't get
into them last time,
and I don't think I'll be
able to finish them today.
But I would like today to be
sort of the closing for what's
needed for the problem set
due Monday and for the quiz
next week.
So, shortly after
today's lecture
I will send you an
email telling you
where the cutoff is
as far as the reading
and the lecture notes.
And I also hope to post the
lecture notes by tomorrow.
And I also will be posting
a set of review problems
as we had for quiz one.
And I hope to get
that done by tomorrow.
You may have noticed that not
all of my hopes are filled,
but I do my best, and I'll try.
OK are there any logistic
questions or anything
before we go on?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you
post the solutions
to the previous
problem set, the one
that we turned in on Friday?
PROFESSOR: Oh, um,
yes I can, I should.
OK I will.
OK, that's a third item I
should try to get done today.
Thanks for reminding me.
And the solutions
to the problem set
that you'll be
handing in Monday will
be posted very shortly
after you hand them in
so that people can
start talking about them
and prepare for the quiz.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do we have any day at
which the videos might be up?
PROFESSOR: Ah, I've request
about that and all I was told
was that they're
doing their best.
So, I did look into it, but
I don't know the answer.
I hope that you'll have all
the videos available to study
for the quiz, but I don't
know if that's going to happen
or not.
OK.
in that case, the new topic
is Blackbody Radiation
and the Early History
of the Universe.
So far we've dealt
with a universe which
contains only
non-relativistic matter
and that, as we said
from the beginning,
describes our universe for
the bulk of its history.
But in the early
period, the universe
was in fact dominated
by radiation,
as we will now be calculating.
And in the more recent
period, the universe
is dominated by
dark energy, which
we'll be talking about
immediately after we
finish talking about radiation.
So the important point here is
that even though we don't think
of light as having
mass, light certainly
has energy and
relativistically we
know that energy and
mass are equivalent.
The key equation that actually
dominates today's lecture
is perhaps the most
famous equation physics,
E equals MC squared, energy
and mass are equivalent.
And the numbers--
I'll just give you
some numbers for this equation.
You've probably already
aware that the numbers
are kind of out of sight.
One kilogram, a point
to that equation,
is equivalent to-- I don't
have any figures to give you--
8.9876, in case you really want
to know it accurately, times 10
to the 16th, most important
to know the exponent there,
joules.
And it's also perhaps
interesting to translate this
into the kind of
energy units that
are use when we talk
about power consumption
in practical situations.
It corresponds to 2.497 times
10 to the 10th kilowatt hours,
which is a lot of
kilowatt hours.
An interesting comparison, is
the total power consumption
of the world, which
turns out to be
comparable to a kilograms
worth of things.
I looked things up
in the Wikipedia,
and it told me that
in 2008-- which
is the most recent year
it had numbers for,
which is a little surprising,
that's so far in the past--
the total world
power consumption
for the year equaled about,
I'm rounding off here,
about 150 petawatt hours.
Now, I always have to look
up peta when I see it,
I haven't quite learned
what peta means yet.
But they translated this, this
means 150 trillion kilowatt
hours.
So 150 times 10 to the
12th kilowatt hours.
And if we divide this by the
number of hours in the year--
to ask how much
is per hour, which
is I think a natural thing to
think about if you're using
kilowatt hours to measure the
power, especially the energy--
the power that goes with
this is about 17 times 10
to the ninth kilowatts.
And therefore 17 times 10 to
the 9th kilowatt hours per hour.
And if you compare
these two numbers,
it means that if you could
convert one kilogram per hour
into pure energy,
that would be about
equal to 1.5 times the
world's power usage in 2008.
So if you could convert
matter completely to energy,
as they do on Star
Trek, it would
mean that you could
fill up your tank
of your typical
American car and power
the world for about two days.
But of course we
can't undo this,
that's the important
fact concerning power.
Only a small
fraction of the mass
of the uranium in
a nuclear reactor
is actually converted as
power, a fraction of a percent.
So you don't get
nearly as much power
as this calculation
would indicate,
but in principle
this much energy
is contained in the matter that
we have around us all the time.
OK.
I want to introduce
a few formulas which
we'll be using sooner
or later concerning
the relativistic treatment
of momentum and energy,
which is what we're
getting into here.
And we're not trying to derive
relativity in this course,
so I'm just trying to quote the
results that we'll be needing.
So, it is useful to introduce
an energy momentum four-vector,
which has a 0-th component
and an i-th component,
where i refers to the
spatial indices 1, 2, and 3.
And sometimes I might
write this as p zero p
with a vector sign over it,
where the vector sign indicates
the three components 1, 2, 3.
The momentum here
is the momentum.
It differs in its
relationship to velocity
from what we have
from Newton, and I'll
write that in a minute,
but this momentum
is the conserved physical
momentum of an object.
And p0 is also conserved.
p0 is just an abbreviation
for the energy divided by C.
And this quantity forms
a four dimensional
vector in special relativity.
And when we say that
it's a four-vector,
we're actually making
a definite statement
about how it transforms from
one Lorentz frame to another.
a four-vector is
something which transforms
in exactly the same way as x
super mu, four spatial and time
coordinates transform.
And in particular,
we learned that there
was an invariant associated with
spacetime transformations this
s squared, which was x squared
plus y squared plus z squared
minus C squared t squared.
And the same thing
will happen here.
p squared, which means
the Lorentz invariant
square of the four-vector is the
Lorentz [INAUDIBLE] again here,
and it's again equal to the
sum of the squares of the 3
spatial components minus the
square of the time component.
And that can be written out as
the square of the momentum--
spatial momentum-- minus
E squared C squared.
And the claim is that this
is also Lorentz invariant.
And we could figure out what
Lorentz invariant quantity
it's equal to by
having knowledge
that this is the
same in all frames.
We can evaluate it in
the simplest frame.
And the simplest frame would be
the rest frame of the object.
In the rest frame of the
object the p would be zero
and this would then just be
minus E squared over C squared.
E squared would be M
squared C to the fourth,
so that implies that this is
equal to minus M0 C squared
squared where M0 is often
called the rest mass.
And when I say it's often called
the the rest mass, what I mean
is that nobody ever
mistakes the word "rest
mass" to mean anything else,
if anybody says "rest mass,"
and he knows what he's
talking about, he means this.
But this is often sometimes
just called the mass
because sometimes people
only talk about masses
as being rest masses.
But I'll try to
call this the rest
mass because I will use the
word mass in other ways.
We could also relate this
momentum to the velocity,
and in doing that we will again
encounter this factor of gamma
that we found
kinematically earlier.
AUDIENCE: Yes, question.
Did you forget to divide
by C squared there?
PROFESSOR: Um, yes.
There's too many C's here.
Absolutely.
It should have
units of momentum.
So it should have units of
mass times velocity squared.
Thank you.
So, the quantity gamma,
is the same quantity
we encounter at the
beginning of the course
when we talked about
time dilation and Lorentz
contraction, it just depends
on the velocity and approaches
infinity as the velocity
approaches the speed of light.
And the physical momentum of
a particle, relativistically
is equal to gamma
times M sub 0 times V.
Where V is the ordinary
velocity-- this
is special relativity,
we're not concerned
with coordinate velocity
versus physical velocity yet--
and gamma is that factor.
So the momentum is larger than
what you would get a la Newton.
The energy can also
be written down.
And this formula
is one expression
we can use to find the energy
in terms of the momentum.
The energy in terms
of the momentum
is M0 C squared squared
plus p squared C squared.
And it also can be written
in terms of the velocity
as just gamma times M0 C squared
where the velocity appears
in the gamma.
And a special case of this is
when the particle is at rest.
Might as well write this, the
energy of a particle at rest,
which we might call E0, is just
M0 C squared, which gets us
back to where we started
with E equals MC squared.
Now, I might just
say a quick word
about where these formulas come
from, what idea underlies them.
I'm not going to
make any attempt
to derive them because
we just don't have time.
It'd be easy to drive them,
but we want to do other things.
But logically,
where they come from
is simply the observation,
by Einstein originally,
that if one has the Lorentz
transformations relating
what one inertial observer sees
to another inertial observer,
if one used those
transformations but used
the Newtonian definitions
of energy and momentum,
then you would find immediately
that if energy and momentum
were conserved in one frame you
then know how to calculate what
happens in other frames by
using the transformations,
you'd find it would not
be conserved other frames.
So if the conservation
of energy and momentum
are to be a universal principle
of physics, which Einstein
wanted to maintain, it would
be necessary to redefine
energy and momentum.
Now they're defined in
ways so that they approach
the Newtonian values
for small velocities,
but for velocities of the
order of the speed of light
they're different.
And they have the property--
not completely obvious from what
we wrote, well it is actually
completely obvious from what
we wrote-- they
have the property
that if it's
conserved in on frame,
it's conserved in all frames.
And what makes it
obvious-- maybe
the connections between
these different formulas
are not obvious--
but I did tell you
that p super mu transforms
as a four-vector,
meaning it transforms the same
way as x super mu transforms,
which are linear
transformations.
And that's enough to guarantee
that if p mu is conserved
in one frame, it has to
be conserved in all frames
because delta p mu,
the change in p mu,
would also be a four-vector,
and if a four-vector vanishes
in one frame, it
vanishes in all frames.
OK.
Well I wanted to give you
sort of a quick example of how
this works in practice.
So I to just talk about the
energetics of a hydrogen atom.
A hydrogen atom
consists of a proton,
with a mass that we'll call
M sub p, and an electron,
with the mass that
we'll call M sub
E. And, as, if you imagine
starting with the electron
and proton arbitrarily far
apart and bring them together,
what you can discover
experimentally-- of if you know
quantum mechanics
you can calculate
theoretically--
energy is released,
because you're releasing
potential energy as you
bring the electron
into the atom.
And the amount of
energy released
is 13.6 electron volts.
And the important
E equals MC squared
implication which I
want to point out here
is that loss of energy.
This energy would be
extracted from the system
as you made the hydrogen atom.
The fact that you've extracted
energy from the system
means that now the system
should have less energy
than it had to start with.
Initially it had the
rest energy of the proton
and the rest of electronic, M
sub p C squared and M sub E C
squared.
Now it has less
energy by delta E,
and that means it also
has to have less mass.
So the mass of a
hydrogen atom is not
the sum of the mass of
the proton and electron,
as it would be in
Newtonian mechanics,
but is less by an
amount proportional
to this energy given off,
delta E, 13.6 electron volts.
And just putting in
the C squares in I
hope the right places, the
mass of a hydrogen atom
will be equal to
the mass of a proton
plus the mass of an
electron, but then
minus the binding energy
expressed in mass units-- delta
E over C squared.
OK.
So I guess, just
probably one more topic
I want to talk about in terms of
just basic special relativity,
and this actually get's
into general relativity.
I wanted to find the
relativistic mass
of any system just being its
energy divided by C squared.
And this means that the
relativistic mass of a particle
increases with its velocity.
The energy of a
single moving particle
is gamma times M0 C squared.
That would say the
by this definition
the relativistic mass of that
particle is gamma times M0.
And I might mention that this
concept of relativistic mass
is disparaged in many books
on special relativity.
It's certainly a concept
that you can do without,
so people who emotionally
are bothered by it
can get along without
it because it is just
the energy divided by C squared.
And in fact a lot of work
in special relativity
is done in units
where C is equal to 1
and then it is just the energy.
Especially if you
use C equals 1 you
could dispense with this
concept of relativistic mass.
We're not going to
be using C equals 1,
so the phrase
relativistic mass will
allow us to abbreviate
E divided by E
squared in a convenient way.
But the important thing
is not the definitions,
the important thing
is what properties
does this relativistic
mass have,
whether or not one chooses
to call it relativistic mass
or E divided by C squared.
And it as an important
property concerning
the gravitational field
created by matter.
Now the gravitational field
of a single moving object
is complicated.
If we were talking
about, say, a moving star
that was moving at a
velocity large enough
so we care about relativity, the
way we calculate that actually
as we start with the
Schwarzschild metric, which
will describe the metric of
the star outside of the matter
if it were stationary.
And then you can just
make a transformation
to a moving frame.
You're allowed to
use any coordinates
you want in general
relativity, so transforming
to coordinates that describe
the moving frame is no problem.
But it distorts the field in a
complicated way, nonetheless,
a way that you can deal with.
And what you find, of
course, is that what
you get would be asymmetric
once you transform to the moving
frame, it would show the
signs of the velocity
that you used to transform
from the original spherically
symmetric Schwarzschild
metric to the new frame.
So the bottom line is that the
gravitational field of a moving
object is not isotropic, it's
more complicated than that,
just as the electric
field would be.
But if we have a
gas of particles,
which is pretty much what we
have in the early universe.
If we have a gas of particles
in a box moving every which way,
then if we thought of this
box as being an object
that we're only going to
look at from the outside--
a black box in the
classic use of the phrase
black box-- the mass
of the black box
really would just be the sum
of the relativistic masses
of the particles.
And the isotropy of the metric
that any one particle would
generate would be canceled
by averaging or summing
over all the particles going
every which direction, because
on average the velocity of
particles inside the box is 0.
So this relativistic mass, when
you're talking about a gas,
really is the mass per particle.
And if you divide
that by the volume
really you do get
the mass density,
which is a relevant
mass density in terms
of talking about how
this matter would
generate gravitational fields.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So why
do some people have
emotional problems with it?
PROFESSOR: I think some people
have emotional problems with it
because when one thinks
about pedagogy in a course,
for example, one worries
about people confusing it
with the rest mass.
I think that's the reason.
And I guess there are other
possible sources of confusion,
so your question is a good one.
Another source of confusion
is that this mass does not
fit into an F
equals ma equation.
So in calling this
the mass you might
suggest to students who aren't
paying attention to every word
that you say, you might
go ahead and put F equals
ma for this mass,
that does not work.
So it has some of the
properties of a mass,
but not-- by no
means all of them.
But in particular
for us is important
because we're going to be
interested in the gravitational
field of a gas
and then it really
is the mass that
determines that.
In the more formal language
in general relativity,
it's the mass-- it's
the energy density, that
appears in the equations that
produce gravitational fields,
and then this really
is the energy density
except for a factor
of C squared.
OK, any questions?
Because now I'm going
to leave this formalism
and get into what role
this radiation could
play in the early universe.
So now I'd like to talk about
radiation in particular,
and for now I mean
electromagnetic radiation
just ordinary photons.
And we're not accustomed
to thinking of light
as having mass,
but we know light
has energy and energy is
related to mass by a factor of C
squared.
So we can write down
the formula that
says that rho is equal to
u divided by C squared.
Where u is the
energy density, which
we know electromagnetic
fields have.
And rho will be the mass
density of radiation.
Now, photons have
zero rest mass,
so if we apply for example
this formula for a photon
we would set M sub 0 equal to 0.
And we said that photons
have zero rest mass what
we mean is that
there's no lower limit
to the energy a photon can have.
In general, the
rest mass determines
the lowest possible energy
a particle could have,
which is when it's at rest.
Photon can never
be rest and there's
no lower limit to what
its energy can be.
So for photons, M0 is
equal to 0 and that
implies that the
energy of the photon
is just C times the
magnitude of its momentum.
And this formula one can derive
just for electromagnetic waves
is purely classical
EM-- you don't
have to be talking
about photons,
but since it's true for a
classical electromagnetic wave
it had better also be true
for photons because we think
of this classical
electromagnetic waves
as really being
made out of photons.
So the energy that
exists in the universe
in the form of
electromagnetic radiation
will have an energy density,
which we know how to calculate.
And we know to calculate the
momentum of any given photon.
Now that will average
to zero, but nonetheless
if we imagine talking about
a box of photons, which
are bouncing off
the walls, the fact
that each photon
carries momentum
means that there will be
a pressure on the walls.
And we will be interested
in that pressure,
we'll be calculating a
formula for it in a minute.
So, what we now
want to talk about
is what happens when we put a
photon gas into the universe
and allow the
universe to expand.
What happens to the
radiation energy density,
or equivalently mass density,
as the universe expands?
This turns out to be
a very easy question
to answer if we
think of the energy
as being made out of photons.
We would get an equivalent
identical answer
if we use classical
Maxwell's equations
and talked about how
energy density is
a [INAUDIBLE] of
electromagnetic fields behaved.
It would be more work
actually do it that way,
but we would get
the same answer.
In terms of photos,
we could simply
notice that the number
density of photons-- photons
are not going to disappear
as the universe expands,
the number density
will just keep
the same number of photons,
but as the universe expands
those photons will
occupy a larger volume.
So it's exactly
the same as what we
said about
non-relativistic matter,
the number density of
photons will fall like 1
over the cube of the
scale factor, which just
says that photons are conserved.
And the volume of any
region grows like a cubed.
I should also mention
that I'm using gamma here.
Gamma of course also
sometimes meant 1
over the square-root of 1
minus V squared over C squared,
but besides that
use, gamma is also
just a label that means photons.
It comes from the
idea of gamma rays,
but it's actually
used in this context
for any kind of a
photon no matter
what its frequency
is, whether it's
a gamma ray or an x-ray or
visible light, or infrared.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is this
assumed for time average?
Because photons can
be absorbed, right?
I mean, at least like
in a small [? slice ?]
can't there be a decided
non-relativistic matter?
PROFESSOR: Is this
true on the--?
Well, the validity of
this formula-- you're
right this formula's not
exact, photons can be absorbed.
But in terms of what happens
as the universe evolves,
that's a very, very,
very minor process,
especially when we're talking
about the early universe
when there isn't really
anything around to absorb them.
So, especially for the early
universe and even pretty well
today, if we're talking
about the cosmic background
radiation, which is the
bulk of the photons,
this formula's a very
good approximation.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Even though the
photons in the early universe
created a lot of
massive particles,
[INAUDIBLE] didn't that
affect the expansion?
PROFESSOR: Are you're
asking, will the photons
be important if there's a
lot of mass of particles?
Is that your question?
AUDIENCE: Would the
photons, won't they
decay into matter antimatter?
PROFESSOR: Will the photon
No, not really.
It is, in principle,
possible for two photons
to collide and produce an
electron positron pair.
It's actually a rather small
cross section for that.
And all of these processes
in the early universe
will rapidly reach
an equilibrium,
which we'll be talking about
more a little later, where
there'll be just as many
photons converting into E plus E
minus pairs as there will be
E plus E minus pairs colliding
and making photons.
So the early universe is
assumed to reach equilibrium
very quickly, and all the
description we'll be giving
will be a description
of the universe that's
in thermal equilibrium
with these processes will
tend to iron out.
We will learn that
they don't always
cancel each other because
the universe is cooling,
and that means it can't be
exactly in thermal equilibrium.
And there are some cases where
the effect of that cooling
is significant and we'll
be talking about those.
But for the most part,
if the cooling is slow,
which it is for the most part
compared to other processes,
everything stays in
thermal equilibrium.
OK.
Those are good questions.
We've gotten a little ahead of
what I wanted to talk about.
So for now I'm just
imagining a free photon gas,
which is an excellent
approximation
for the early universe.
And those photons
just continue to exist
as the universe expands,
so their number density
falls off as 1 over a cubed.
But there's another
affect that goes
on which is that the
photons are redshifting.
And we already know
about that, but now we're
going to take it into account
in terms of the energy balances.
So we know that the frequency
of a photon at some time t2
divide by its frequency
at some time t1,
and here nu equals
frequency, is just
diluted by the expansion
of the universe.
This ratio is 1
over 1 plus z, where
z is the redshift
between these two times.
But written out in
more detail which
is a formula we'll
actually be using,
is just a of t1
divided by a of t2.
When the scale factor doubles,
all the frequency is half.
And that means that all
the photons are lowering
in frequency, and we also know
that photons are quantized.
The energy of a photon
can't be any old thing,
but in fact, the energy of a
photon is equal to h times nu.
Where little h is what's
called Planck's constant.
And numerically there
are various units
you could express it
in, but it's 4.136 times
10 to the minus 15th
electron volt seconds.
So if you measure a
frequency an inverse seconds,
you get an energy in electron
volts from that formula.
The important thing
for now though is
that this says that the
energy of each photon-- being
proportional to its frequency,
and the frequency being
proportional to 1 over
the scale factor--
the energy of each photons is
proportional to 1 over a of t.
And then the total
energy density
of photons in
photon on gas which
I'll call u sub gamma, the
energy density of the gas,
can be thought of as the
number density of photons
times the energy of each photon.
And the number
density is falling off
like 1 over a cubed, the energy
is falling off like 1 over a.
And therefore, this
is proportional to 1
over a to the fourth.
So as the universe
expands, the density
of non-relativistic matter
falls off like 1 over a cubed--
as we've been talking
about some time now--
but the energy of
radiation falls off faster,
like 1 over a to
the fourth because
of the red shifting
of the photons.
OK, now once we know
this, we can ask ourselves
what happens if we look at
our universe going backwards,
knowing where we are
now where we come from?
And if the energy
density of photons
is falling off faster than
the energy density of matter,
it would mean that the
ratio is getting smaller
as we go forward in time.
But that of course
implies that the ratio
gets larger as we go
backwards in time.
So as we go backwards
in time, the radiation
becomes more and more
important, and there actually
is going to be a time when the
radiation will equal the matter
and at earlier times the
radiation will dominate.
Today I'll just give
you a number for now,
we'll learn later
how to calculate it,
but for today the
total radiation energy
density in the universe
is equal to 7.01 times 10
to the minus 14 joules
per meter cubed.
And this actually includes
two kinds of radiation,
it includes photons
and also neutrinos,
which at least in
the early universe
behaved just like radiation.
And we'll be talking more about
neutrinos later so don't worry
if you don't have any
idea what a neutrino is.
But for now it's just another
contribution to the radiation,
and we can measure
basically this is all
based on measuring
the temperature
of the cosmic microwave
background radiation--
and we'll learn later how
to make that conversion.
But once you measure
the temperature
of the cosmic
background radiation
and have a theory about how
many neutrinos there should be,
that's actually all
theoretical and we'll
talk about that later as well.
One can determine
what the energy
density of that radiation is.
And it corresponds to a mass
density just dividing by C
squared of 7.80 times 10 to the
minus 31 kilograms per meter
cubed.
And when I think
of mass densities
I always like to think of in
centimeters per-- excuse me,
grams per centimeter
cubed because I'm
used to the density of water
being one gram per centimeter
cubed and I like to be able
to make that comparison.
So just making that conversion,
usually I use SI units,
but some things just seem to
make more sense in other units.
So it's 10 to the minus 34
grams per centimeter cubed,
so 10 to the minus 34, or
maybe 10 to the minus 33,
times the density of water.
And this is incredibly
low even compared
to the critical density
of our universe,
and the actual
density we know is
very near this critical density.
Let me remind you that
the critical density
we derived a formula for,
and when we put numbers
into that formula
we found that was
equal to 1.88 times
little h0 squared,
which is Hubble's units--
Hubble's constant in units
of 100 kilometers per
second per megaparsec--
I'll write that in
a second-- times 10
to the minus 29 grams
per centimeter cubed.
So just writing down the
equation for little h sub 0
is where capital H sub 0,
Hubble's expansion rate,
is equal to 100
times little h sub 0
kilometers per second
per megaparsec.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: What's
the, I guess, what's
the motivation of
normalizing the Hubble
constant in this way?
PROFESSOR: Well, I think
the real motivation is
that the astronomers like these
peculiar units of kilometers
per second per megaparsec, but
if your favorite unit is called
a kilometer per
second per megaparsec
you don't want to have to
say those units very often.
So H0 is dimensionless, so
it's a dimensionless way
of talking about
the Hubble constant.
But that's the only
importance, there's
no real-- no deep
significance to it.
But it's a standard notation,
so it's worth knowing.
And then finally,
we can write down
how much the radiation
contributes to omega-- omega
sub r, r is going to
indicate radiation.
The notation, by
the way, will be--
and I realized I've already
violated that notation.
This really should have been r.
Well, I'm not going to change
it, it'll get too messy.
But I'm going to start using the
notation where gamma indicates
photons and little r
indicates radiation.
And the difference is that there
are other kinds of radiation
besides photons, in
particular we've already
added in neutrinos in part of
what we're calling radiation.
So omega sub r, which now
includes photons and neutrinos,
is just defined to be the
mass density radiation divided
by the critical density.
And that turns out, when
you combine these numbers,
to be 4.15 times 10 to the minus
5 little h0 to the minus 2.
And then for h0 equals 0.67,
which is the Planck satellite
value for little
h0, we finally get
omega sub r is equal to 9.2
times 10 to the minus 5.
So roughly 10 to the minus 4.
The fraction of the mass
density, or energy density
today is about 10 to the minus
4 fraction and radiation.
And actually as I write
this, this actually
calls to mind another reason for
defining little h sub 0, which
is that if you write formulas
in terms of little h sub 0,
they remain valid between
one year and next year.
The observational value
of the Hubble parameter
is still floating
around and differs,
for example, every time
I teach this course.
So the formulas in
terms of little h sub 0
stay, and then you plug in the
current value of little h sub 0
to get the best value that
one can currently write down.
Now we know the Hubble constant
to within a few percent, which
is much better than it used to
be, but it's still floating.
The Planck value was somewhat
lower than the previous except
a value, which was about 0.70.
OK.
So we know enough information
to extrapolate backwards
and calculate when
this radiation would've
equaled the energy
density of matter.
Because we know how
the ratio changes.
It changes by a factor
of a, the scale factor,
because the energy density
of non-relativistic matter
is falling off like
1 over a cubed.
The energy density of
radiation is flowing off like 1
over a to the fourth.
So the ratio between
them just changes
by a factor of a,
decreasing as a gets larger.
So we can write RHO radiation
of t divided by RHO matter of t.
The m there means
non-relativistic matter.
This is just equal
to the current value.
And the current value is
gotten by taking that number
and, where I forgot to write
down is that omega matter today
is about 0.30.
So the ratio of the two, omega
radiation over omega matter,
which is the same as RHO
radiation over RHO matter,
is about 3.1 times
10 to the minus 4.
And that number is about
to appear in this equation.
If we want the ratio
as a function of time,
we start with this value today,
3.1 times 10 to the minus 4,
and then we can just multiply
that by the scale factor
today divided by the
scale factor at the time
that we want to know it, because
we know it falls off as 1
over the scale factor.
And by putting an a
of t0 here, this just
guarantees that if
we let t equal t0,
we get this number, which is
the right ratio for today.
OK.
Now it's just a
matter of arithmetic.
We also know that for a
matter-dominated universe.
And for now, we're going to
estimate when the radiation
energy will equal
the matter density.
This will only be an estimate.
We're going to
estimate it by assuming
that we can approximate the
universe as matter dominated
between now, all the way
back until that time.
There are two errors
in that calculation.
We're not taking into account
here the era of acceleration
where dark energy is
playing a significant role.
We'll learn later
how to do that.
And also, as we approach
this time when they're
making equal contributions,
we will run into a regime
where the contribution
of the radiation
itself will be relevant.
So this is only an estimate.
But what we're
going to do is we're
going to assume that
we can treat this
as a matter-dominated universe
with a of t proportional
to the 2/3.
And then we can plug
numbers into this formula
and ask, when was the ratio 1?
And when the ratio
was 1, we call
that the time of equality, using
the subscript EQ for equality
to indicate anything having to
do with that crossing point.
And what we find is
that the z of equality,
and z is just the ratio
of the a's, is-- according
to this calculation, it
would be 3.1 times 10
to the minus 4 minus 1.
I fibbed when I said that
z is the ratio of the a's.
It's offset by a little bit.
It's 1 plus z that's
the ratio of the a's.
And that's why there's
a minus 1 there.
And numerically, this is
about equal to 32,000.
So if we look back in the
history of the universe,
we can define looking back
in terms of the redshift.
If you look back to a redshift
of 3,200, we get to the time
when matter and radiation
had the same energy density.
And we can know what time
that is if we assume t
to the 2/3, which again is
only a crude approximation.
We don't necessarily expect
to get the right answer here.
But we expect to get the
right order of magnitude.
So t-equality, according
to this situation,
would be about 75,000 years
after the Big Bang-- just
converting the scale
factor that we just
calculated to a time using that
formula, treating this as t
to the 2/3.
So this says that about
75,000 years after the Big
Bang, the energy densities
of matter and radiation
were equal.
In the earlier
times, the universe
was radiation dominated.
The radiation exceeded the
matter in its energy density.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It seems like
zEQ is relatively about 31
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You might be
right if we would just
look to these formulas.
When I calculated
this at home, I
kept more decimal
places all the way
and rounded off each answer
to one significant figure.
And that's not the same as
taking the answer to one
significant figure
and calculating
and then rounding off
to ones in every figure.
So I think there's always an
ambiguity of, roughly speaking,
1 in the last decimal
place whenever
you're rounding numbers off.
AUDIENCE: So we just
plug that [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 3,220--
starting with this
or starting with a more
accurate number than the 3.1.
AUDIENCE: Just 1/3.1.
PROFESSOR: 1/3.1.
OK.
So, OK?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Wait no,
[INAUDIBLE] like we have 1
over 3 times 10 negative 4.
That's 3 times 10--
PROFESSOR: It's 3.1.
AUDIENCE: You have 1 over 3.1.
PROFESSOR: 1 over 3.1.
So you have to divide.
AUDIENCE:I do that all the time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So apparently
it's even right
if you just calculate with that.
But there is actually
some ambiguity.
The numbers I'm
giving you probably
have some uncertainty
of 1 in the last digit,
depending on how you calculate.
But the number they
give you, I think
they're the ones that
you get if you start
using this and the 0.67 and
from then on do everything
to large numbers
in decimal places
and round off at each stage.
You'll get the numbers
I've given you.
In any case, all these
are really, at best,
order of magnitude estimates.
So worrying about whether or
not the last figure is accurate
is not a big deal.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I don't
really understand
how you got t [INAUDIBLE]
without telling was a of t dot
is [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry.
There is actually a
piece of information
I used I forgot to write here.
You're absolutely right.
I used t0 is equal to 13.8
times 10 to the nine years.
And then everything
can be related to t0
if you know how things
are proportional to t.
You're absolute right.
I did not give you
all the information
necessary for that calculation.
Now I think I have.
I haven't done the
arithmetic for you.
But otherwise it's all there.
OK.
Now I might mention
that in Ryden's book,
she does the calculation taking
into account everything--
matter, radiation,
cosmological constants.
And her number for
t-equality is 47,000 years,
which verifies that we have
the right order of magnitude.
And actually, the
biggest difference
between her number
and my number is not
that she's taken into account
these more sophisticated
things, but rather that
she used a different value
for the Hubble expansion
rate than I'm using.
She's using a value that was
current at the time she wrote
her book, which was
like '72, I think.
h0 equals 0.72 instead
of [INAUDIBLE] 0.67.
And that does make a
significant difference here.
But either of these numbers
are, I think, probably
within the range of uncertainty
of when it really happened.
But it's on that scale, on the
scale of 50,000 years, 100,000
years, something of that order.
So there was a
significantly long period
compared to human lifetime
when the universe was
radiation dominated.
But it's a very small fraction
of the overall history
of the universe,
but nonetheless does
have important features that
happened during that time
period.
Now, if we want to
understand those features,
we have to understand how a
radiation-dominated universe
evolves, which is what
we're going to get to next.
OK.
The next little
chapter than I'm going
to be talking
about-- the dynamics
of a radiation-dominated
universe.
This is a chapter
that you more or less
get to work out the
equations for yourself
on one of the homework problems.
That's part of this week's set.
So I will try here
to outline the logic.
But because all the calculations
are in the homework,
I will basically skip the
calculations themselves,
and let you do
them for yourselves
as part of the homework.
But where we start is we have
written down Friedman equations
for the matter-dominated case.
And I'll start by reminding
us what those were.
And then in addition to
these two equations, which
describe our expanding universe,
which we've derived sometime
ago for-- and to
remind us here, this
is for a matter-dominated
universe.
And matter-dominated means
non-relativistic matter
dominated.
And going along with
these equations,
we also know that RHO of t
for non-relativistic matter
falls off like one
over a cubed of t.
This can be converted into a
differential equation for RHO.
That is, we can calculate
Rho dot from this equation.
And the way to see that
is probably most easily
to start on a new blackboard
and write that equation not as
a proportionality, since
it's hard to differentiate
a proportionality,
but we can write it
in an arbitrary constant
of proportionality.
And then it becomes an equality.
So I'm going to write
the equation as RHO of t
is equal to some constant,
b, divided by a cubed of t.
And this we know how
to differentiate.
We can write Rho dot is
equal to minus b over a
to the fourth of t times a dot.
And that is equal to minus 3.
I'm sorry--there's a 3 here.
Minus 3 times a dot over
a times the original RHO.
So we can forget the
intermediate steps,
and we just arrived
at the equation
that RHO dot is equal to minus
3 a dot over a times RHO.
And we can think of
that as going along
with equations one and two.
Maybe I'll even
give that a number.
Equation three
will be RHO dot is
equal to minus 3 a
dot over a times RHO.
Now for radiation,
there will be a 4 here.
The 4 will arrive the same
way as the 3 arrives there.
It's just the power that
appeared in the factor of a.
So for radiation, this
last formula we know
is going to be modified,
which is the key point.
Note that these three
formulas are not
independent of each other.
If we know, for example,
equation one, which
is an equation for
a dot, we could
differentiate that
with respect to time
and get an equation
for a double dot.
When we do that, everything
has to be differentiated.
So it involves
differentiating a,
but that just expresses things
in terms of derivatives of a.
But the new quantity that
gets introduced is RHO.
If we wanted to differentiate
this equation with respect
to time, we have to
know what RHO dot is.
But we do.
That's what equation
three tells us.
So we can differentiate equation
one, use equation three,
and we can derive an
equation for a double dot.
And if these equations
are consistent,
it'd better be equation two.
And it will be.
You can check it.
And actually, I think any
two of these equations
can be used to derive the third.
Those equations
just are-- really
a set of two
independent equations
and one dependent equation.
You can shuffle it
any way you want.
But, now what we want
to do is to consider
a different kind of matter.
Instead of
non-relativistic matter,
we're considering photon matter.
And in particular,
we know that it's
going to change equation three.
So for radiation,
3 gets modified
into 3 prime, which
is the equation that
says that RHO dot is equal to
minus 4 a dot over a times RHO.
So how are we going to
fix these equations?
Now they're inconsistent.
If we change three and don't
change either one or two,
we know that we're
inconsistent, because any two
of those equations can be
used to derive the third.
So we're in trouble.
Either equations
one or two will also
have to be modified if we're
going to modify equation three.
OK.
Before we go on, I'd like to
say a little more about why
this equation is different
from that equation.
One might think
that it should just
be governed by the
conservation of energy.
After all, we just
write down an equation
for RHO dot-- how energy
density changes with time.
Shouldn't conservation
of energy determine that?
It does.
But there is an extra element
to conservation of energy
that we need to
take into account,
and that is the pressure
of the gas affects
what happens to its
energy as it expands.
So before we get back
to the early universe,
I just want to consider a
gas in a piston chamber.
And I'm going to let the piston
have an area a, and inside
we're going to have a volume
v. Just to define our notation.
If we have a gas
inside a piston chamber
and let the piston chamber
enlarge by pulling out
on the piston, the gas has
a pressure, in general,
and that pressure will
exert a force on the piston.
So if I allow the piston
to move to the right,
that gas will be
exerting a force
on the piston in the
direction that it's moving.
And that means the gas will
be doing work on the piston.
So, by our ordinary notions
of Newtonian conservation
of energy, we would know that
the gas would lose energy,
and we can even calculate
how much energy it loses.
And the formula is easy enough
to get in a Newtonian context.
It's just du is equal
to minus the pressure
of the gas times the
change in volume.
A famous formula.
And this just comes
about by saying
that the work that's done is
the force times the distance.
The force is the
pressure times the area.
And the volume is the
area times the distance.
And putting those
things together,
you get this
formula immediately.
Now this formula is
actually much more general
than the quasi derivation
that I just showed.
It works no matter what
the shape of the gas is.
If you put a gas in
any kind of a container
and let that container enlarge,
even in an irregular way,
the work that the gas
will do will always
be equal to minus the
pressure of the gas
times the change in the volume.
We can apply this to
the early universe.
It actually works.
The difference
between our two cases
is that our non-relativistic
matter has no pressure at all.
We're just talking about
particles sitting at rest.
They're not bouncing
off of any walls.
They're not creating
any pressure,
while the photons are
moving around all the time.
And if you imagine
a box of them,
they'd be hitting against
the walls of that box,
exerting a pressure.
And we're now in a position
to relate the pressure
to the difference between
the 3's and the 4's that
appear in those two equations
for RHO dot in the two cases.
To apply this naive idea
to a piece of the universe,
we can imagine choosing-- we're
going to choose some fixed
volume in our co-moving
coordinate system.
So our box, the volume
that we're talking about
will actually be expanding
with the universe
but be fixed in
co-moving coordinates.
And the physical volume
therefore of our box
will be a cubed of t times
the coordinate volume
of the box-- the volume
and not just cubed.
And this volume will
be independent of time.
There's time dependents there.
The physical volume of
our box will be enlarging.
The total energy in our
box, the total gas energy,
which I'll call
capital U, will just
be the physical volume
times the energy density.
The energy density is
energy per physical volume.
And we can now
apply this formula
using this U and this v.
And here again is one
of these cases where
I'm going to be skipping
steps because you're
going to be doing it in
detail on the homework.
But by putting these
equations together,
what you'll find is that d dt
of a cubed times RHO times c
squared-- this is just d dt
of a cubed times the energy
density-- basically,
the left hand side
of that equation divided by dt
and divided by v coordinates--
is equal to minus p
times d dt of a cubed.
And this is just the PDV
term from the right hand side
of that equation rewritten
in terms of the variables.
And you'll be doing
this for homework.
I'm just getting
straight the factors
to make sure I have them right.
OK.
Reshuffling that
equation-- and again, this
is a homework problem--
you can turn that
into an equation for RHO dot.
And what you'll get
is minus 3 a dot
over a times RHO plus
p over c squared.
And now we can see how
our two cases emerge.
If the pressure is 0,
we get minus 3 a dot
over 8 times RHO,
which is what we
had for non-relativistic matter.
And the photon gas is
going to have a pressure,
and we could read
off from this formula
to know what the pressure has
to be to turn the 3 into a 4.
The pressure has to be
a factor of a third.
So you determine for this
that the pressure for light
is 1/3 of the energy density,
or 1/3 times RHO c squared.
And that's what you need
to turn the 3 into a 4.
So we now have indirectly
calculated the pressure
of light, and this agrees
with any other calculation
for the pressure of
light that you might do.
It's by no means the
only way to calculate it.
And now finally,
we're in a position--
and we'll just do
this quickly to decide
how to modify these equations.
Now, we're not in a position
to determine that rigorously.
It can be determined rigorously
by doing general relativity,
which we're not
doing at that level.
But we can still
motivate the answer.
One of these two
equations is going
to have to be changed
to accommodate
a more general
expression for RHO dot.
The top equation
we know is really
an equation for
conservation of energy.
That's how we got it
in the Newtonian case
where little k ended up
being partial to the energy
in the Newtonian case.
But this is basically
a conservation
of energy equation.
And that's what you
expect, just given
your general notion
of mechanics as well.
If you have a second
order equation,
a second order differential
is with respect to time.
That's the force equation.
And if you have a first
order differential
equation with respect to time,
1/2 mv squared plus v of r
equals constant.
That's energy conservation.
Same thing here.
And we know that energy
cannot suddenly change.
If we imagine-- I guess the
first experiment I want to do
is imagining somehow
there's an explosion
throughout all of space.
I imagine putting pieces
of TNT throughout space
and arranging for, at the same
cosmic time, for all of them
to be ignited.
And that would suddenly change
the pressure of the universe,
but it would not change
the energy density.
The energy density
would be conserved.
So the bottom line is
that pressures can change
discontinuously, but
energy densities cannot.
And since this equation is
the conservation of energy
equation, we'd expected that
nothing can change suddenly
here, that the pressure
term cannot contribute here,
because if it did, the pressure
term would changed suddenly.
Nothing else in this equation
would change suddenly.
There would be no way the
equation could be satisfied.
But if we added a pressure
term to the second equation,
that would allow the pressure
to change discontinuously
as the TNT went off.
And that would change a
double dot discontinuously.
And there's nothing wrong
with a double dot changing
discontinuously.
If you suddenly the apply
a new force to a particle,
you suddenly change its second
derivative of its motion.
You suddenly change
its acceleration.
So that's OK.
So any pressure to
this term make sense.
Adding pressure to this
equation does not make sense.
And then we can just
ask, what do you
have to do to this equation if
we're going to add a pressure
term to make all
three equations now
consistent with the new
equation for RHO dot?
It's your homework problem
to answer that question,
but the homework
tells you the answer,
and I'll write the answer
on the board right now,
and then we'll consider
today's lecture over.
The bottom line is that
equation number one
has to be modified
into one prime, which
says that equation number
two has to be modified.
What am I talking about?
And the new equation
is a double dot
is equal to minus 4
pi over 3 G times RHO
plus 3p over c squared times a.
And now we have a consistent
set of Friedman equations,
and these are the
Friedman equations
that we would have gotten
if we had done everything
using general relativity
from the beginning.
And we'll stop there.
And we will meet
again next Tuesday.
And I'll send you an
email about-- there
will be at least one homework
problem on the problems set
that will have to be held over
to the following problems set.
I'll send you an
email about that
and post it on the website.